3.1415926535 I'm Jacob
Barandes this is my daughter Sadie this is pi
Pi is a magical number because it appears to
be written into the architecture of
logic of the universe itself shows up
all over mathematics and physics and
other areas of the sciences it is
irrational meaning it cannot be written
as a whole number divided by a whole
number but it's beyond irrational it's
actually a transcendental irrational
number it is not the solution to any
algebraic equation you can write down
with a finite number of terms and people
have been fascinated by pi for centuries
and we still are
... 1... um... um... 6402862... 342117067
All right let me
make sure it's right say
help me out okay, 0348
2534217067 yes we did it!